-I'm looking for a friend.
-Come on, buddy!
-I have a friend here today
who was in the live taping.
-You have a friend here?
-At the taping.
And I didn't -- I think it
was just by coincidence.
-Oh, really?
-Stand up and wave right now.
-Here.
-Hey, buddy! I miss you!
-Hi.
-Yay!
We did "Dear Evan Hansen"
together.
-Oh, my God. Not too shabby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome. Welcome to the show.
-That's Mateo Lizcano.
He was one of
our brilliant Evans
and he's a stunning performer
and awesome friend.
-But here's one of the things
that I love about you,
'cause I know your act
and we all know you from
"Stranger Things"
and you're great on the show
and a good actor
and you're funny.
-Thanks, buddy.
-You can sing, buddy.
You can real--
-Eh! Thank you.
-You're a Broadway-trained actor
and you can sing.
You're phenomenal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-I mean, it is insane.
-That's very nice.
-It always blows me away.
I love it.
-Thank you.
Thank you so much.
-You're very, very talented.
-Thank you.
-We have to talk about
"Stranger Things."
-Please!
-Last time we were on the show,
it was about to --
second part
was about to come out.
-That's right.
-Couldn't say anything.
And then you and
our buddy Joseph Quinn
just kind of won
the Internet there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love that guy.
-Well, what do you like about,
like, when people come up to you
and talk about
"Stranger Things"?
Do you just go, "Oh, yeah,
it's cool" or do you --
-Oh, of course it's cool.
I think it's just --
It's interesting to
constantly just be
reminded how much
people have resonated with it.
I mean, it's something that's
so important to all of us
and has just been
essential to, like,
the growth that I've had
over the past --
over all of my teenage years
into my 20s.
And it's like --
It's the defining aspect
of the past 10 years of my life,
practically, the past decade.
-So when people get moved,
you go,
"Yeah, I'm also moved, too,
because it's part of my life."
-Exactly, exactly.
It's the fact that at least
something I've been a part of
can do that for people.
It's kind of still sinking in,
I think, and it's wonderful.
-Yeah, well, this the --
They're wrapping it up.
-One more, yeah.
-One more.
Like, they're -- Is it --
It's got to be bittersweet.
-Of course it is, you know?
I mean, there's kind of
like a --
There's an excitement there,
'cause you always want to
wrap it up and you want to see
how these characters
are going to finally
develop one last time
and how they're going to
finish their journeys.
But, also, it's just --
There's, like, a deep fear
that's been, like --
Not only has it been amazing,
but it's been, like,
pretty great job security
for the past --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
You're like,
"What am I gonna do?"
-Back to freelance.
-Oh, I'm going to bawl
my brains out.
-Me too.
-I'm going to be so sad.
But what are your hopes
for Dustin?
What happens?
-I don't know.
I think it's in
the best hands it can be.
Matt and Ross
know these characters
better than I think we might.
And it's really interesting,
'cause they trust us
all very much
to make our own decisions
and go about the scenes the way
we've always instinctually
wanted to.
And I've never really
given myself an opportunity
to think of what
they might want to do,
and now's
the best time to start.
You know what I mean?
Just really thinking about
what can happen.
I'd just -- I'd love to see
a good launchpad for growth
and I'd love to see
these characters thrive
and move on from
the trauma they've endured
over the past few years.
-You think? Yeah, yeah.
A little, yeah.
But, gosh,
those Duffer brothers,
yeah, they know what
they're doing.
-Yeah, they're -- they're --
They ain't shabby.
-Yeah! They're not too shabby.
No, they're not too shabby.
-That's for sure.
-Could I talk about
something, too, also?
We've mentioned
a couple times on our show,
but you work closely with
an organization
called CCD Smiles.
-Yeah!
Thank you so much for the plug.
-No, but you do so much
for that organization,
and I just wanted to say
that's cool that you do that.
-Thank you.
-I noticed that.
You know, even when
you're not on our show --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, thank you.
Yeah, I love it.
-Can you maybe explain
what that is,
if anyone doesn't know
what it is?
-Yeah. I think I've talked about
it on the show before,
-CCD Smiles.
CCD is short for
cleidocranial dysplasia.
It's a condition I have myself,
as well as many other
wonderful people
who I've gotten to meet.
And my main goal --
Of course, we're there to
raise money for the people can
get the treatments they need,
which can range from
dental surgeries
and implants and things
like that and can also --
There's a whole array of things
that we're just figuring out
that are associated with CCD.
That's my biggest goal
is to let this organization
be a beacon for people
and for medical professionals
so people can learn from
those who are experiencing it.
-Start the conversation.
-Exactly.
That's what's great is,
you can't expect
medical professionals and
doctors to know all the answers.
So it's really quite
a cool feeling
when you can teach somebody
who's been -- who's an expert
in so many fields
and help them learn
and help them
treat patients better based on
the experiences you've had,
and that's what's really cool.
Like, my family has a bakery,
and we're doing
this thing where --
on ccdsmiles.org
and on our bakery's website,
Joe's Bake Shop --
you can buy, like, cookies,
and a lot of the proceeds
will go to CCD Smiles.
-There you go.
So check it out, please.
-If you like food --
-We love food.
I've had them before.
They're delicious.
-Yes, indeed.
I brought them last time.
-Yeah, I know. I love it. Yeah.
Let's talk about "Sweeney Todd."
-Yeah, sure.
-People are excited
about this, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Me too!
-This is a big deal.
-It is! It's cool!
-Back on Broadway,
and you've been doing Broadway
most of your life.
-Yeah, since I was 9 years old.
-9.
-Yeah.
-I found a photo of you
signing autographs
backstage at Broadway.
-This is -- Yeah.
-Look at this little guy.
-The Palace Theatre.
Yeah!
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Oh, boy.
-What's it like being a kid --
a Broadway kid?
I mean, just --
I mean, I know there's a lot --
But you just --
-Bananas.
-Yeah.
-It's great. It's so cool.
-What are you like,
say, at karaoke?
Like, what if I -- Are you fun
or are you too good,
where I just go,
"I got to leave"?
-No, theater kids are
never fun at karaoke,
because, like, everyone's there
to, like, be drunk
and have a good time,
but, like, Broadway kids --
they're, like, in the bathroom.
They're like...
They're, like,
getting tea beforehand.
-You're warming your throat up?
-They're, like, warming up
and they're like,
"Ah, I can't mess this up."
-Yeah, and some of them
are going like...
♪ I'm a Barbie girl ♪
♪ In a Barbie world ♪
And you're like,
"Me, me, me, me, me."
-But we always, like,
put the biggest damper on
the night by doing, like,
some, like, really sad ballad.
And they're like,
"Great. Who's this guy?"
-Like, what would you do?
-I sang -- There were
a good number of them.
My first song I ever sang was
"Fly Me to the Moon"
by Frank Sinatra.
That was really fun.
-At 9 years old?
-At 6 years old at this point.
I remember, I did --
I had a fedora and everything.
I did this little hat trick
where I did, like, a flip,
and people just loved it.
-Yeah. That thing.
-But I did -- There was one time
I sang "Bring Him Home"
from "Les Mis," which is,
like, a beautiful song,
but at karaoke night...
Like, read the room, dude.
-We want "Don't --" Yeah,
we want "Don't Stop Believin'."
-Exactly.
-"Sweeney Todd" --
what do people --
What should people think
about -- know going into this?
-I love when people know nothing
about a show going in,
but what I love about this
production specifically is that
lovers of this show,
lovers of Stephen Sondheim
will absolutely adore it,
'cause it's Sweeney
bigger than ever.
You know what I mean?
It's back on Broadway, but it's
a huge cast, 26-piece orchestra,
wonderful group of people
that are just --
It's at this incredible size
that it once was in '79,
when it opened -- or 1980,
when it opened originally
on Broadway,
and we're back to that scale.
And to just hear it ring out
in the Lunt-Fontanne,
which is a beautiful theater,
big house, and --
-And directed by Thomas Kail.
-Tommy Kail.
-Who did -- No big deal.
He directed "Hamilton."
Yeah, no, not a big deal.
I mean, people are
excited about this.
-Alex Lacamoire
supervising our music,
who is just an absolute genius.
-He is actually a genius.
-Absolute genius,
worked on "Hamilton" with Tommy
and "Dear Evan Hansen,"
which I got to work on him
with, as well.
-But if you haven't
seen the play
or know anything about this,
how do you --
You describe it as a barber.
-Yeah.
I think it's quite interesting.
The pitch
was probably really interesting.
-Yeah, how would you
even ever pitch this?
-It's like -- It's a
classic, brilliant, powerful,
booming musical that
also combines, like,
a slasher comedy.
And that's pretty wild
to describe,
but it's just
quintessential Sondheim.
When you talk about
his best works,
this is always talked about
as one of the top three,
if not, like, the show.
-A barber who murders everyone.
-A lot of people.
-If you sit down in his
barber chair, he kills you.
-And it's not even,
like, a spoiler.
It's called "The Demon Barber of
Fleet Street."
Like, he's probably
not the coolest.
-But he -- Then he works with
a pie shop...
-Yes, indeed.
-...to kind of help
dispose of the bodies.
-It's fun.
-Yeah, it's fun
for the whole family.
-It's great! They sing songs.
-Everyone check it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's going to be so much fun.
Opening this weekend.
We love you, buddy.
Break a leg. Gaten Matarazzo.
"Sweeney Todd"
is now playing on Broadway
at the Lunt-Fontanne Theatre.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.